all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning it
was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other just in case you're still
jonesing for more friends content
have no fear jennifer aniston is here
we'll find out on tuesday the
52-year-old actress took to instagram to
share
these sweet behind-the-scenes snapshots
from the friends the reunion set
that's jen with all her co-stars david
schwimmer
courtney cox matt leblanc lisa cudrow
and
matthew perry but this snap begs the
question
where's the pic that jen actually took
here oh
that's interesting she captioned the
post quote still basking
in all the love from the friends reunion
thank you each
and every one of you jen also teased the
second photo in the post
david on the central perk couch next to
justin and hayley bieber
writing when two totally different
worlds collide
david schwimmer's face says it all of
course justin was a guest star on the
hbo max special that aired last week
modeling ross's really bad halloween
costume from
season eight what are you supposed to be
remember the russian
satellite sputnik yeah justin worked the
catwalk in that
unique ensemble hey all right
ross came as duty
jennifer also posted a sweet selfie she
snapped with legendary tv director james
burroughs
who helmed most of the show's first
season and helped establish it as the
cultural phenomenon it is today
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this
the last pick in the post a cartoon of
the stars sitting on a couch in front of
a fountain
taken from the show's iconic intro
the caption could this be any more of a
small outdoor gathering with vaccinated
friends
what's not to like the friends reunion
marked the first time the cast had all
been together
on the set of the hit sitcom since the
show wrapped 17 years ago
and the whole thing was emotional for
every single one of them
the best way that i can describe it is
after the show was
over at a party or any any kind of
social gathering
if one of us bumped into each other that
was it that was the end of the night
you just sat with them sat with the
person
all night long i remember that was it
and all that echoes what the cast told
et about their tight bond
even decades after the show first
premiered in 1994.
the first question like how do you feel
i was like
and then started crying and then i
walked on the set and i had no idea
that seeing everything look exactly the
same and these incredible friends
it was just the most emotional thing
from the first table read of the pilot
without having met
any of the others beforehand we all felt
kind of an
instant chemistry going way back it's a
very loving
tight-knit group and when we see each
other it's a
it's a very heart-warming thing
you